ahora aprendamos un poco sobre fluidos y
es muy probable que ustedes tengan ya
una idea al respecto un fluído es
cualquier cosa que toma la forma de lo
que lo contiene por ejemplo si yo tengo
una esfera de vidrio completamente llena
de agua aunque no mejor digamos que es
una esfera de plástico si yo fuera a
cambiar la forma de esta esfera y se
viera así el agua cambiaría su forma al
igual que su contenedor y lo mismo
sucedería si esto fuera oxígeno o algún
gas llenaría el contenedor y se
adaptaría a la forma de éste
entonces un fluido pase igual
a lo que toma la forma de su contenedor
toma la forma del contenedor
y tenemos dos tipos de fluidos los
líquidos
y los gases al ser el gas comprimido
aquí pongo que el gas es comprimido
y la diferencia con los líquidos es que
los líquidos no se comprimen no son
comprimidos
como les decía al ser el gas comprimido
se puede reducir el volumen del
contenedor y el gas se va a volver más
denso en cambio los líquidos no se
pueden comprimir imaginen el mismo globo
lleno de agua o mi esfera de plástico si
quisiéramos comprimir este globo por
todas partes al mismo tiempo no
podríamos reducir su volumen sin
importar que hagamos en cambio si este
globo estuviera lleno de gas si
podríamos disminuir el volumen si
hiciéramos presión en todos los lados
del globo y esta es la diferencia entre
un líquido y un gas ahora vamos a
enfocarnos un poco más en los líquidos
para aprender un poco más sobre el
movimiento de los líquidos y de ahí al
movimiento de los fluidos en general
vamos a limpiar la pantalla
ahora imaginemos una situación en donde
tenemos un contenedor de una forma muy
peculiar como este y que el área de la
primera abertura es a1 y el área de la
segunda abertura es a 2 tenemos este
contenedor con algún líquido más o menos
así y recordemos que los líquidos no se
pueden comprimir ahora recordemos lo que
sabemos de trabajo y veamos si podemos
deducir algunas reglas de fuerza y
presión en los líquidos
recordemos que trabajo w un esfuerzo por
distancia
y de la ventaja mecánica aprendimos que
el trabajo de entrada es igual al
trabajo de salida wv e iguala w
al trabajo de salida que viene de la ley
de la conservación de la energía
recordemos que la energía de entrada
será igual a la energía de salida debido
a que ninguna energía se crea o se
destruye solamente se transforma así que
sustituimos esta fórmula del trabajo
aquí y tenemos
efe fuerza de entrada por la distancia
de entrada va a ser igual a la fuerza de
salida por la distancia de salida ahora
imaginemos que voy a comprimir y oprimir
a a1 con cierta fuerza usando algo así
como un pistón más o menos así aquí esta
f1 que es la fuerza con la que estoy
oprimiendo o empujando hacia abajo el
pistón y este líquido va a bajar
una distancia de 1 así que el pistón se
va a desplazar una distancia de 1 y aquí
mi pregunta es cuánta agua se va a
desplazar o cuál es el volumen de agua
que se desplazará aquí en el área a 2
el volumen desplazado es igual a la
distancia por el área ya que bueno esta
sección de a1 es como un cilindro así
que ve uno es igual a uno por de uno y
recordemos que un líquido no puede
comprimir su volumen todo este volumen
desplazado se verá reflejado aumentando
algo el nivel de este otro lado en a2
aquí vamos a tener una distancia de 2
como podemos conocer esta nueva
distancia al comprimir este lado de a1
se va a recorrer todo el líquido y se va
a desplazar algo en el otro lado por lo
que el volumen que se desplazó en a1
será el mismo volumen que se desplaza en
a 2 cuál será ese cambio de volumen de 2
igual a distancia 2 por área 2
y de nuevo recordamos que este líquido
no se puede comprimir por lo que el
volumen es el mismo así que tenemos a
uno por de uno iguala a dos por de dos y
también sabemos que la fuerza que entra
aquí es la fuerza que sale pero se nos
acaba el tiempo nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo